[Music]
in this video i'll show you how to build
and deploy a recommendation system with
bigquery ml
my name is polong lin and i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud
from finding the right halloween costume
getting notified of relevant spooky
decorations for your home
the majority of consumers today expect
personalization
recommendations of products and services
or content
tailored to their interests and so in
order to better serve the customers
businesses need to be able to train and
deploy recommendation systems
quickly and effectively to improve
conversions
click-through rates and build customer
satisfaction loyalty and brand affinity
but to build recommendation systems you
need a place
for your data google bigquery is a fully
managed highly scalable data warehouse
solution
on google cloud and comes with lots of
great features
especially around storage and analytics
without needing to move your data out of
bigquery
with bigquery ml you can train and
deploy machine learning models
directly using sql that means you've got
data storage
analytics and machine learning all
within bigquery
so how can businesses create
recommendation systems
quickly and deploy them into their
online stores
in this video i'll show you how to
prepare your training data in bigquery
train a recommendation system with
bigquery ml
use the predicted recommendations in
production and
tips and best practices let's start
with the data to recommend something to
someone
you kind of need to know what they like
already
so how do you know what a user likes in
general
there are two ways if your users
directly give you ratings of four and a
half stars out of five on a particular
product or piece of content then this is
called
explicit feedback the second way is to
infer
interest indirectly for example maybe
the more time a user spends viewing a
product
the more they're interested in it since
you're inferring interest
indirectly or implicitly this is called
implicit feedback
as implicit feedback tends to be more
common in retail businesses
let's build a recommendation system
using some sample implicit feedback data
from a real online store the google
merchandise store
is an actual ecommerce store where
people can shop for google branded
shirts
hats and other products in a sample of
the anonymized google
analytics data is available as one of
the bigquery public
data sets based on the store's google
analytics data
i've cleaned the data so that we can see
each anonymized visitor id
what product they were looking at and
how long they spent viewing the product
which is in milliseconds here we need
these three columns
to train a recommendation system in
bigquery ml
the user the product and the ratings
so the visitor in the first row for
example viewed a particular item for
59 milliseconds and in the second row
a different visitor looked at this item
before 5
787 milliseconds and so on
so essentially the more time they spend
viewing the product
the higher the implicit rating
with the data ready to train the
recommendation system
we'll be using the matrix factorization
algorithm
in bigquery ml so selecting the data is
straightforward here
select star from the view or table
with the training data we can now create
the model
by specifying a model name like retail
recommender in our data set
bqml then we specify the options
model type which in this case is matrix
factorization
for recommendation systems the user
column the item column and the rating
column
and setting feedback type to implicit
because the model is trained differently
for explicit and implicit feedback
and then within as we select the
training data
now as you execute this query if you get
an error that says
training matrix factorization models is
not available for on-demand usage
it's because matrix factorization can be
quite computationally expensive
so bigquery is trying to protect you
from a potentially hefty bill
to rectify this you will need to use
flat rate pricing
and to learn more about this follow the
guide in the link here
after training is done you can evaluate
your model using select star from
ml.evaluate but you might be wondering
what data it's
evaluating the model on when you create
a model
bigquery ml automatically splits the
training data into its own
training and testing data behind the
scenes for you
so this allows you to evaluate your
model immediately
after the model has finished training
now of these evaluation metrics
average rank also known as mean
percentile rank
is perhaps the most widely used metric
for implicit matrix factorization
in general the lower the average rank
the more closely
the predicted recommendations match the
behavior in the test set
with 0.5 being random chance and 0 being
a perfect
prediction if you're happy with the
evaluation metrics you can now make
predictions
to make predictions with bigquery ml on
a single user
or set of users to start you can run
select star from
ml.recommend specifying the model you
created
and the user id or ids that you want to
make predictions for
to get the top n recommendations you can
order by
the predicted confidence descending and
limit
n you can also make predictions
on all of the users so you have the top
n recommendations for
every single user for example here we're
looking at the top
five recommendations for all the users
note that because the output for
predicting the top n
recommendations for every single user
can actually get quite large
and because we may want to use the
results multiple times
it may be better to store the outputs in
a separate table
that you can reference more easily later
like here
prod recommendations under the bqml
dataset
now that we have our predicted
recommendations what can we do
to use the recommendations in production
one way is to export recommendations for
ad retargeting campaigns with google
analytics
first by focusing on specific products
at a time
you can create a new column for
likelihood to purchase
this product based on the predicted
recommendations
then you can import your predictions
back
into google analytics to create new
campaigns for those products
another way is by connecting the
predicted recommendations with your crm
like salesforce and by doing so you can
create targeted email campaigns
to provide relevant products directly to
your customers inboxes
there are even integrations between
google analytics and salesforce that you
can leverage
you can also export the recommendations
to cloud storage
a separate database or simply read from
bigquery to use
in a separate service to serve the
recommendations
now at this point i want to cover some
tips and best practices
as you might be thinking how you can
potentially improve your recommendation
systems
in production one question you might
have is
what happens to new users in other words
since matrix factorization can only make
predictions on users
who belong to the training data how do
you make predictions on users who you
don't have any data for
well this is actually a common problem
called the cold start problem
there are many ways to deal with this
which is outside the scope of this video
but as a simple suggestion the easiest
way would be to show new
users items that are sorted by
popularity
or what products have been trending for
the past time interval
another question you may ask is how do
you recommend items to new users
if you know some of their demographic
data one way is to find local likes
to those new users based on your pool of
existing users
for example given some demographic data
for
user x first compare user x
to all of the existing users that you
already have recommendations for
then find the five most similar users
we'll call these local likes to user x
based on whatever data you may have
demographic data or otherwise
then make recommendations to user x
based on what these local likes would
themselves
be recommended to find local likes
one way is to use cosine similarity
between user x
and the other users another way that you
can find local likes
is to find the nearest cluster of users
and use them
as your look-alikes and you can do this
using a clustering algorithm
like k-means which is also available
with bigquery ml
for example given four clusters of users
we may find that user x is closest in
distance
to the centroid of these yellow square
data points
and so we can recommend to user x
products
that the user in this cluster would
themselves be recommended
another question you may have is that
bigquery ml does batch predictions very
well
but your business may need predictions
on a single user at a time
and you need the predictions to be fast
in these situations
you can export your matrix factorization
models from
bigquery ml and host it for real-time
predictions
using ai platform on google cloud to
learn more about how to host these
models for real-time predictions
you can follow this link so now
you should know how to build and deploy
a recommendation system
with bigquery ml thanks for watching